aujourd'hui dans le tiroir caisse nous
allons vous faire un petit tour
d'horizon de l'économie grecque et qui
de mieux qu'un véritable grec pour vous
en parler est salut à tous et nikos un
bienvenue dans le tiroir cache
aujourd'hui au programme je parle de mon
merveilleux pays d'origine la clé et je
ne parle pas de la dernière liposuccion
de kim kardashian
dix ans après la crise la grèce va mieux
en tout cas un peu mieux depuis trois
ans elle a renoué avec la croissance de
1 5% du pib en 2010 7 à 1,9 en 2018
avec même une prévision de croissance
au-dessus des 2% pour 2025 rôle oble
encore mieux qu'une performance
d'ailleurs qu'à gauche aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe à canal nakamura c'est vous le
gouvernement grec le chômage devrait
passer de 17,4 points en 2019 à 15,6 en
2020 les amis c'est une belle salle
croyable aussi incroyable que la baisse
des audiences de the voice c'est
essentiellement grâce au tourisme qui
marche plutôt bien
des signes encourageants quant on sait
que le chômage a dépassé et 28% au plus
fort de la crise lire qu'une crise de
nerfs de britney spears ou de mariah
carey ou après la dette grecque restent
énormes 177 % du pib
quand on sait que la france était morte
de trouille quand lucien a dépassé les
100%
on imagine la sérénité des grecs une
dette qui est détenu majoritairement par
les acteurs institutionnels
comprenez l'union
n et le fmi qui ont accepté de repousser
le remboursement jusqu'à 2060 c'est bien
sûr la grèce continue de faire des
efforts vector softcity boussac à la
grèce reprend enfin des couleurs et
c'est pas pour nous déplaire
on se retrouve très vite donc 50 minutes
cash
[Applaudissements]